abone ol
en
[Müzik]
iyi akşamlar
bu Tekrardan iyi akşamlar
olimpiyat öncesinde okuduğum ve bazen
hayatımda karar vermekte zorlandığım
anlarda tanıştığım bir kitapta bir söze
denk gelmiştim bir nesnenin değerini
onunla nereye ulaştığınızda değil ona ne
ödediğinize size kaça mal olduğuna
bağlıdır diyor
olimpiyat madalyalı elime aldığım zaman
aklıma ilk gelen şeylerden biri de buydu
tam 12 yıl
tam 12 yıl boyunca bir gün bu madalyayı
kavuşmanın hayaliyle yaşadım En başa
dönecek olursak boksla tanışmam Hatta
spora başlamanın tamamıyla tesadüf
Aslında ailem için de çok
çok güzel bir tesadüf değil yani erkek
kardeşim kolunu kırdıktan sonra çok
ağrılı ve sancılı bir dönem geçirdi çok
uzun bir dönem Fizik Tedavi gördü ve
kolunu yüzdeyüz anlamıyla
kullanılmıyordu
doktorumuzun anneme
sporla birlikte İşimiz daha da
kolaylaşır demesiyle evimizin
yakınlarındaki bir spor salonuna Annem
erkek kardeşim yazdırdı Tabii bu süreçte
de Annem çalıştığı için yolda başka bir
sakatlık olmaması adına erkek kardeşime
Ben eşlik ediyorum birkaç hafta salona
gidip gelirken ben sadece ders
kitaplarının yanında götürüyorum o
çalışana kadar onu bekliyorum antrenmanı
bitince onunla birlikte eve geri
dönüyoruz
o birkaç hafta sonra hala 12 yıldır
birlikte çalıştığım antrenörüm bana sen
Neden bekliyorsun sen de erkek
kardeşimle birlikte çalış akşam eve
beraber geri dönersiniz dedi bu ya ben
de olabilir aslında diyerek o gün
antremana başladım
Birkaç ay sonra annem hem erkek
kardeşimin Hem de benim genel olarak
durumunu öğrenmek için antrenörü ile
görüşmeye geldi antrenörüm ilk başta
böyle biraz anneme bakarak ikisi beraber
geliyor ama ha Kız daha yetenekli erkeği
başka bir branş alamıyorum destekledi
Tabi o zamana kadar sporcu bir aileden
gelmediğim için spor yapan bir aile
geçmişim ailemin geçmişi sporla bütün
değil boksu tanımıyoruz Türkiye'de erkek
spor olarak adlandırıyor ailem için
karar alınması zor bir durum olsa da
onlar benim bir şeyler başarabileceği M
inandığı için arkamda destek olarak bu
spora başlama yardım E
tabii ailem annem antrenörüm de görüşene
kadar Ben antrenmanlarda hem kız hem de
erkek partner bulmakta zorlanıyorum
çünkü kimse Benimle çalışmak istemiyor
Benimle çalışan tek kişi erkek kardeşim
o da akşam beni evlendirme şikayet
ediyor ablamın vuruyor diyor annem de
bana kardeşini de ben vuruyorsunuz
sürekli Tabii
işin içinde olduğum için o zamana kadar
bunu algılayamadım ve tabi yaşım küçük
olduğu için antrenörü böyle bir adım
atmasından sonra anneminde destek
olmasıyla benim için profesyonel olarak
sporculuk hayatı tam olarak başlamış
oldum daha zor antrenmanlar daha iyi
dinlenme daha iyi beslenme daha iyi
dinlenme özel hayata eskisi kadar zaman
ayıramama git var
ama bunları bir zaman sonra isteyerek
hayallerimin peşinden koşmak istediğimiz
fark ederek çok daha istekli bir şekilde
yapmaya başladım ama tabii uzun bir süre
başarısızlıkla geçen bir dönemde var bu
dönemde de Hepimiz gibi bende iki
cephede savaşmaya başladım hem dış cephe
hem de iç cephe ve dış cephe her zaman
daha kolay aslında kimin ve
yarışacağı mı Kime nasıl bir strateji
uygulayabileceği mi biliyor ama ilk
cephe hepimiz için daha zor yanınıza
gibi görünen başarısızlığı mızı isteyen
ya da yaptım sporun bana yakışmadığını
düşünen az da olsa bir kesin
bunlarla mücadele etmeye başlarken hem
de mücadele ederken aynı zaman da
başarısız olmam onlar için biraz daha
konuşma imkanı yarattı Diyebiliriz ama
bir zaman sonra başarmaya ve madalya
ulaşmaya başladıkça bu kesimi daha çok
mutsuz ettiğini fark ettim onların
konuşması Benim onların konuşmasından
daha çok güç alarak ilmimi yükseltmem
onları mutsuz beni de mutlu ediyordu
erkek spor olarak adlandırdıkları sporum
da ya da bana yakışmadığını düşündükleri
eldivenleriyle önce Avrupa şampiyonu
sonra Avrupa oyunları şampiyonu sonra
Avrupa'nın en iyi boksörü dünya ikincisi
ve şuan olimpiyat Gümüş madalya sahibi
sporcu olarak karşımızda duruyor
da
çok zorlu geçen ve yorucu geçen bir
dönemi Sonrasında da
olimpiyatlarda yaşayabilmek
olimpiyatlarda sahne alabilmek benim
için çok önemliydi
olimpiyat final günü işler benim için
yolunda gitmemiş gibi göründü Yani en
azından o zaman ben öyle zannediyordum
Daha sonrasında kendi başıma kaldığımda
ben Bu zamana kadar hep bir olimpiyat
hayali kuruyorum hep bir olimpiyat altın
madalyası istiyorum ama şimdiki Gümüş
madalya mno2 olimpiyat hayali daha
kurduğunu fark ettim
bu telefonla odada annemle ilk
görüştüğümde çok ağladım çok üzüldüm
Annem bana
boşu an orada olduğum için ne iş
başardığını farkında değilsin Türkiye'ye
geldiğinde bunu anlayacaksın dedi
Gerçekten de öyle Türkiye'ye geldiğimde
çok güzel geri dönüşler aldım çok güzel
insanlarla karşılaştım Çok güzel
düşünceler duydum ama beni en mutlu eden
anlardan biri ben Olimpiyatlar Ken
mahalledeki bütün esnafın kendi arasında
para toplayıp benim kocaman bir pankart
mı Yapıp mahalleye asmalar Iy dışı Hepsi
benden daha heyecanlı olimpiyat Madalya
mı alıp mahalleme geri dönmemi
bekliyorlardı bende Artık olimpiyatta
erken onların heyecanını gördün müsün
artık Bitsin gideyim onlar da rahat
etsin Artık rahat uyusunlar diye
düşünmeye başlamıştım mı Eve geldikten
sonra herkese mahalledeki tek tek bütün
oturan küçük genç yaşlı herkes Ceo
pankartın altında fotoğraf çekildim Daha
sonrasında bir gün fotoğraf çekimi
bitmeye yakın mahallemizin çok eski
esnaflarından biri Buse pankartı
yaptıran esnaf seninle bir fotoğraf
çekilmek istiyor dedi Ben de Tabi olur
dedim ya da yüzü şöyle mi yapsak Sen
madalyayı boynuna taksam biz tek tek
dükkanları geçtik fotoğraf çekilsek
dedim ki abi o artık belediye
başkanlığına giriyor ona şu an değil
daha sonra olay daha sonra gerçekten ben
ne kadar desteklediklerini ve ne kadar
bu duyguyu aç olduklarını hissettim
Benim için en önemli anlardan biriydi
gerçekten ömrüm boyunca unutamayacağım
onlardan bir Tabi bu kadar başarılı
olmadığım bir süreç daha var mm 38
yılında performansının belki de en iyi
olduğu dönemlerden birinde çok iyi
hazırlandığımız bir dünya
Şampiyonası'nda İlk turda eğlendim
Secret spor yaptığım için çok zor kilo
düşüyorum ve gerçekten maça yakın bir
süre
istediğim kadar istediğim derecede
beslenemiyorum o gece odama geri geldim
telefonumu kapattım kendime bir makarna
hazırladım büyük bir tabakta ağlayarak o
makarna yerken sporu bırakma kararı
aldım Artık yapamıyorum artık olmuyor
demek ki buraya kadarmış
Bir iki gün boyunca antrenörüne hiç
konuşmadık Günaydın Merhaba iyi geceler
kesinlikle e olmadı
13. Günün Akşamı bana
yarın Sabah dokuzda kahvaltını yapmış ol
11de antrenman mız var dedi
sonra durup kendi başına düşündüm de ben
çok çabuk mu pes ettim bu kadar
başarısız bir döneme rağmen o hala benim
için çabalıyor dedim gerçekten de
öyleydi tam sekiz gün yenildiğim bir
turnuvada
Türkiye'ye dönene kadar her gün
antrenman maçı yaptım Belki de orada
dünya şampiyonu olsaydım daha az mı açıp
da maç yapıp daha az yorulur dum
gerçekten o süreçten sonra Türkiye'ye
döndüğümde en büyük Başarılarını O andan
sonra yakalamaya başladım Benim için
Kırılma Noktası tamamiyle orası ydı
bıze mini gördüm diyebilirim zemine
gördükten sonra yukarıya çıkmak karar ve
bir araya çıkmak benim için daha kolay
oldu daha da güzel oldu
Onu her zaman inandığım ve çok basit
olan bir felsefe var siz diğer insanlar
ne kadar başarılıysa ben o kadar
başarılıyım Ben o kadar büyük bir
başarının bir parçasıyım benim olimpiyat
madalyam renginden baz alınarak
hepinizin ışığı hepinizin Hun'un Umuda
olsun diyorum siz ne kadar başarılısınız
ben o kadar başarılı Biz o kadar
başarılıyız herkese çok teşekkür
ediyorum hoşçakalın